Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P Here is a caller who's
calling in about my Tesla lease. I'm not exactly
sure what point they want to make and they.
Speaker 5: David. So I'm in the market
for a Tesla. I know your lease and soon
I'll give you 40 grand for it. Let me know. Okay.
Speaker 1: So I don't know what point they're
trying to make. Listen, one of the things I said
a while ago when I decided to lease a Tesla,
I generally lease anyway because it provides tax
advantages If you have an AC corporation and I
have explained, I just maintenance. I explained
all my my financial reasons for going with a lease
in in particular with Tesla. One of the reasons
I wanted to lease and not buy was number one,
A lot of the reliability data, particularly after
three years, is pretty damn shaky and I want
the maintenance on a four year old Tesla to be
someone else's problem and not mine. And I've I've
said before the range unbelievable The charging
network fantastic better than any other brand but
build quality very shaky. The car's been in
the shop multiple times for the same thing
they have it 7 to 10 days. They don't fix it.
They give me a loner that's been beaten to hell.
It all is a long story short, I don't want to
own a Tesla. And so that's the deal with the
lease. It is true that because Tesla cut prices on
these cars multiple times, if I owned the car now,
it would have lost dramatically probably. I mean,
more than $10,000 in value, maybe even closer to
20. So that's another reason I'm really glad that
I don't own this thing and I can just walk away
from the dramatically depreciated vehicle. Now
this guy wants to buy me out of my lease for 40
grand. I don't know what the lease buyout is at
this point. I haven't looked at it, but email me
and we can talk about it. Maybe I'll maybe I'll
send you my car. All right. A bonus show today.
Bernie Sanders has endorsed Joe Biden and is
ruling out running in 2024. There are people
who wrote to me saying Bernie had to do it.
Why? That doesn't make any sense. We'll talk
about it. Number two, Missouri is about to force
trans adults and teens to detransition. The ACLU
is suing. What on earth is happening in Missouri?
And lastly, Justice John Roberts, chief justice
of the Supreme Court is declining an invitation
from the Senate to testify on the ethics of the
Supreme Court. I am sure that Clarence Thomas, his
name, would come up at such a hearing. We'll talk
about all of it on today's. Bonus.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show
where you want to make money.
Speaker 3: Everybody else who
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 4: David Pakman does not have a
soul. He doesn't have a soul.
Speaker 1: You can make heads
or tails out of those comments if you
want, but I tell you the bonus show is
a good time. Sign up. It joined Pacman dot
com. We will see you on the bonus check.